welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on the paternal
merits of the mcu cast that's right here
at new rockstars we celebrate father's
day all year round and today we are
ranking some mcu daddies my name is mt
and i'm here today with someone you may
have seen on recent episodes of the
break room our very own researcher and
what's going on and all yay mt i am so
excited to be here i am even more
excited to be on the mcu dad episode
because uh you know around the office
they they call me the resident daddy
expert
wow
do they actually call you that i mean no
no no one calls me that no one calls me
we could start if you want but let's
start the petition please sign the
petition please well we just missed
father's day this year but it got me
thinking about all the dads at the mcu
be it biological adoptive or otherwise
and there are some really great paternal
figures in the movies but there are also
some
really really bad ones which leads us to
this week's big question who is the
worst daddy in the marvel cinematic
universe
now empty there are so many dads so many
dads so i feel like we've gotta narrow
the scope just a little bit and rate
maybe the worst ten yeah i think that's
good i agree with that and to make it
quantifiable we're gonna do a point
system so i've decided on six categories
that i feel represent what qualities a
good dad should have and those are love
for their kids like do they actually
love their kids treatment of their kids
how do they treat their offspring and
involvement with their kids how involved
they were in all their kids lives their
emotional availability how receptive and
open they are to their children's
emotions and we also have dependability
could their kids rely on them to be
there when they needed it and finally we
have role model potential uh dad jokes
isn't a category i wish i thought of
that um but i'm not too sure about that
one
hi not too sure about that one i'm anna
[Laughter]
i wish you were my dad anna i wish you
were my father let's sign the papers
let's sign the papers today
all right uh but anyways we're gonna
rate each contestant one to five in each
of these categories and whoever has the
lowest number at the end will be deemed
our worst daddy of the day i've
abandoned my child and also a note at
the top we're not taking the comics into
consideration here because you know it's
movies only there's just too many bad
dads in the comics so let's just stick
to the mcu all right all right let's do
it i'm ready mt do you have any papas
you want to start out with um yeah
because we got to start off with one of
the main avengers dads who we were told
right off the bat wasn't the best dad at
all howard stark the original daddy of
the mcu howard stark as we all know is
tony stark's dad and while he has
already passed away by the time we meet
tony stark it's clear that his father
left a pretty big impact on him and not
necessarily in a good way in iron man 2
tony describes his dad as cold and
calculating and says his dad's happiest
day was when he shipped tony off to
boarding school this is not very cool um
and later on the movie we get glimpses
into howard stark's life where he's
entirely focused on his work has an
implicit drinking problem and interacts
with young tony with a callous
disposition he is however told by his
mother that his dad misses him when he's
gone and tony later discovers footage of
his father saying that he's doing all of
this work for him and that tony is his
greatest creation but is it a little bit
too late to rack up those good dad
points
i don't know i mean like oh bark no bite
does not a healthy child make
well like all love bark no love fight
forget it let's drop it let's draw it
okay all right
let's move right along to the first
category okay how are we feeling about
love for kid um
i think that howard stark generally did
love tony i mean he just didn't know how
to express it like my father
whoops he says that everything he built
he built for tony and he believed in
tony enough to be certain that tony was
the only person in the world who could
take over his life work of building this
new element yeah i would agree i would
agree but i would take a point off
because referring to your child as a
creation when you're an inventor is just
like a little weird like does he love
him as a son or as a prodigy
soon
that's a great question very much
i do feel like geppetto vibes it's like
all right you're my greatest puppet
creation my wooded boy
father
i love that voice and the new in the new
pinocchio love it oh my god
all right so let's take a point off and
call it a four so how he felt on the
inside aside how about treatment of kid
anna i'd give him a two for that one i
mean tony did say that his dad never
said he loved him or even that he liked
him and in fact we get a flashback to
when tony is younger and he begrudgingly
maybe but he says i love you and his dad
doesn't say anything back not even
goodbye as he left for another one of
his many trips that made him completely
absent from tony's life so like he gets
a point for not killing him which is a
low bar but to be fair for some of the
dads we'll be looking at we got to take
it into consideration so yeah i think
that's fair i feel like uh one point for
not killing your kid is uh more than
fair because a lot of dads don't get
that point uh let's be real but for
involvement i would also give that a two
because like you said he is always
taking trips and that made him a pretty
absent dad and enrolled today in
boarding school which made him even less
involved and he was at least around here
and there though which is
sort of good yeah what about what about
emotional availability i would give that
um a 25
dollar one straight up generous straight
up it was a straight up cold father uh
yeah howard stark was just more all
about his science and his nerd stuff
than uh being a good caring father who
wants to throw baseballs with his son
so lame and then
dependability maybe like a like a
generous two how can you depend on
someone who's not there you know maybe
like financially depend on him but
that's about it okay but what about role
model potential i think this one's
interesting right and tony hated how he
was raised and despised his dad for it
but also i mean he did take on the
company and the tech and whatnot so
right right you can't hate that badly
when you inherit everything so maybe
like a three bringing the total up to 14
points for howard all right hit us with
another daddy anna daddy expert okay
oh thank you thank you thank you for
using my official title doctor dr daddy
expert oh doctor yeah right uh
let's do let's do hank pym because that
dude always felt a little bit off to me
hank pym is hope van dyne's father and
ant-man and right off the bat some
doesn't seem right since they work
alongside each other and yet she calls
him hank and then later casts the vote
that kicks him out of the company we
find out that when her mother dies when
she was young hank gets lost in grief
and she doesn't see him for two weeks
and then he decides to send her off to
boarding school fast forward and we see
that her relationship with her dad has
grown and they're cool now but
holy timoli he ain't winning a father of
the year awards yeah not at all uh but
love of kid what would you give him
i'd say the same thing as tony that i
think hank genuinely loved his daughter
and wanted to keep her safe but just
didn't know how to show it so
okay four all right all right for
treatment of kid i would say
like a three
no i mean they do have a good
relationship now but
boy not talking to your kid for two
weeks after their mom died and then
sending them to boarding school right
after that's a it's kind of a dick move
it's kind of rough
i'm pretty rough and for that same
reason i'd give involvement a three gone
for a good portion of her childhood but
then i mean she worked for his company
and i think they might have lived
together i'm still not 100
sure there's that like breakfast scene
in the house we stopped serving
breakfast at 11 30.
want breakfast
yeah well hey
i'm really sorry yeah well hey i'm
really sorry too
i don't know maybe yeah i don't know
what's going on there but if they did
live together i would understand because
uh money and uh the economy money
because money
but i mean either way he wasn't that
uninvolved in her life you know true in
emotional availability i'd give like a
two like we're throwing out twos he
eventually learns to open up a little
bit but when she needed him the most he
wasn't there which is you know what
really counts and same for dependability
i'd give it a three because i think he
would generally sacrifice himself for
her but wasn't there when she was a kid
and then for role model potential i'd
say three actually because despite
disliking him for a good amount of time
she does actually look up to him so that
brings our total for hank pym to 18.
18. all right
well let's do another avengers parent
odin because odin is the biological
father of hella and thor and the adopted
father of loki and hello was the
firstborn and odin raised her to be a
warrior to help him conquer the nine
realms and she was assigned the role of
his executioner and commander of his
army but she got a little bit too power
hungry and when she wanted more war odin
banished her to hell and then he found
loki abandoned by the frost giants
because of his size and took him in
raising him alongside thor trying to
keep the fact that he was adopted a
secret but the siblings saw the clear
preference for thor and loki turned
bitter because of that preference and
fast forward and thor tried to stir [ __ ]
up with the frost giants of course but
odin wasn't having any of that [ __ ] so
he banished store to earth along with
mjolnir also known as miami if you are a
fancy person now fast forward more and
loki finds out the truth about his
adoption and out of anger he lets the
frost giants into asgard while his
father is in the odin sweep when having
a nice little nappy and then kills
laughy in the name of his father mixed
messages much a little bit yes um but
fast forward more and there's a lot in
these movies um and loki hurls himself
into a pit at the rejection of his
father but he's alive and there's a
trial and loki is locked away but then
he escapes and then loki disguises
himself as odin and then eggs and exiled
him to earth and then they find him and
he's like yo your sister's coming and i
love you uh but i'm gonna die now and
then he dies i think that about sums it
up
it's good enough for me
and let me tell you empty this dude
drives me crazy man but i'll i'll save
it i'll save my thoughts let's rate him
give him you know let's let's give him
his fair trial so
love for kids um
i'd give him a three because he does
hold love in his heart for like one and
a half kids
this is true in treatment of kids um
it's like he's not an [ __ ] but his
parenting style kind of really sucks
like his version of grounding is just
banishing people that's kind of wild but
he does try to raise them with some love
at least so
how about a three that's fair that's
fair i'd probably say the same thing for
involvement like aside from the one he
banished to hell for literal millennia
he definitely was involved in the other
two's lives it's true that's true and
for emotional availability i feel like
he's kind of available i mean like he's
when he's warm he's warm but when he's
cold that dude is cold um very cold
especially when he's dead okay okay but
how about when loki finds out he's
adopted and he's absolutely pouring his
heart out in despair and owen's just
like
[Music]
i'm so sleepy i can't i can't wow so
boring sorry oh i'm sorry and then he
literally falls asleep
[Laughter]
we'll say three again uh but how about
dependability well how can you depend on
someone who's asleep
this is true like you're really caught
up on the sleep thing though
this is just ridiculous
okay but can his kids depend on him i
mean he did forgive some of loki's
antics when loki needed him but there
were also other times where he was like
totally fine with loki dying or hella
dying or even thor dying and he was a
little just a little too casey ross or
off for me so i'll give him a two there
okay okay
and as a role model not completely
terrible like being a ruler of asgard is
pretty cool but two out of his three
kids didn't really like his ruling style
so i'll give it a three but he
definitely could have been better could
have been worse which brings odin's dad
score to like 17. but who's next anna i
would like to examine fergus e
thunderbolts ross
daddy is ross daddy is ross that's right
daddy is ross
otherwise known as betty ross's dad and
the incredible hulk which is
the only time you see her in the mcu
yeah
i mean their relationship is a major
plot point of that movie things start to
go south when betty and bruce are
recruited into a program commissioned by
her dad to recreate a super soldier
serum which they were lied to about
regarding the serum's true purpose
things go south bruce goes green and
thaddeus roscoe's murderlating all this
data and also i'mma get you and then
dedicated his entire life's mission to
capturing bruce banner which is
obviously a problem for betty because
daddy i love him
and all of this ends in her telling him
not to speak to her as his daughter ever
again so
love for kid where did we jump in
i mean you know i hate to continue the
trend but i'm gonna have to give him a
four because like i think he loves her
and generally tries to make the effort
uh he's just a really he's a hard ass
he's a military dad yeah and honestly
like i think four for treatment of kid
too because sure he was cold and
uncaring towards her boy but like
she's fine she's fine she's totally fine
she's she's she's
[Laughter]
she's a genius that just likes dating
bad boys everyone has their bad boy face
it's fine everyone's got their face
involvement is kind of weird because
it's not like we get to see her
childhood after her mom died in the
movie but there has to be some reason
that she feels distant enough to refer
to him as general instead of dad so like
maybe like a three that's fair i'd
probably say the same for emotional
availability too because honestly there
were moments where i feel like he's very
willing to have a fair conversation but
also he outright admits that his duties
supersede his personal feelings in the
movie so
three
yeah i would say three is
pretty fair um dependability though i'd
have to give him a two because uh the
only thing she's super passionate about
is protecting bruce and he doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about that he's the
kind of dude to be like you can have
anything you want kitten and she's like
anything and he's like anything kitten
and she's like um how about you don't
kidnap my boyfriend father and he's like
absolutely not 100
and for role model potential
regardless of his rank or position she
definitely doesn't look up to him like
she even disowns him so
i mean what is that that's like a
probably like a two
two i'm fine with that i'm fine with
that and that makes dadius ross's score
and 18. well let's move on to a
different
not so great dad um because speaking of
hard asses let's talk about wenmu
and jai ling's father oh this is gonna
be a good one because everything was
sunshine and roses for when wu and his
family up until his wife died because
that will kind of put a damper on most
moods um if you're kind of a bummer if
she was nice anyway um and then things
went really south like really quickly
because hellbent on revenge wenmu
started his son on a rigorous painful
training regiment at just seven years
old when um he should have been bringing
his son to chuck e cheese or some [ __ ]
and took him to watch as he beat up and
killed people who had information on
finding the person who murdered his wife
and while training his son to kill he
was completely ignoring his daughter
unable to even look at her because she
reminded him of his dead wife which is
messed up and uh definitely gave uh
shilling some trauma childhood trauma
not the best knowledge it's gonna be a
therapy session um
yeah therapy session or twelve thousand
and when shunxi was fourteen wenmu sent
him on a hit to kill his mother's
assassin and although shengshi succeeded
shengshi chose not to return instead
running away to the united states six
years later shiling followed suit and
escaped blah blah blah cut to years
later when they're adults and when moose
starts hearing his wife's voice telling
him that she's alive and being kept in
tallow as a prisoner so he sends his
henchmen to steal his sibling's
necklaces fight sheng chi as he tries to
stop him from opening the gate to evil
and then gets his soul sucked out when
the dweller in darkness is released
taylor's oldest time um so many people
have written about this very tale so
many times the epic of gilgamesh
actually this very story absolutely
classic so where do we where do we even
start with this one okay so
love for kid he does
love his kids deep down
but potentially loves one as a weapon
and then completely ignores the other
one right maybe like a three
yeah three
yeah yeah yeah three three a generous
three let's say a generous three
seven three
um for treatment of kids uh just to
summarize he pushes years of harsh
training on one of them kills in front
of him and then when their adults send
people after them imprisons them tries
to kill one of them when they stand in
their way and as a cherry on top blames
chongqi for his mother's death to his
face as a young boy i will grant
one
one
very generous point for how they were
treated before the mom died and because
it truly seems
like he doesn't want to kill shanghi but
he would rather him rule by his side so
like a two a two that is that is very
generous of you and for involvement i
will grant that same point of mercy
because it looked like he was a very
involved father before the mom passed at
least we saw them play ddr once and
really what can we expect ultimate
family
and he does say that even after the kids
ran off he had always known where his
children were which tells me that maybe
he allowed them to keep their distance
like they wanted while he kept a
watchful eye on them maybe which is
either
sweet or creepy so three
it's sweet and creepy sweepy
sweet and creepy combination um
like odin very smelly very sweepy
but for emotional availability i think
we can all agree is a one he completely
shut that side down with his kids once
his wife died so yeah he was not
available at all definitely
dependability i'll give
a two because he gets one point for
finally deciding to give all the rings
to shanghai maybe a little too late like
come on man right as he's dying but
still he did make the decision and that
was probably the one dependable thing
that he did and then role model
potential would be like a two because
shengshi didn't want to be like his dad
at all he did however have to use both
his father and mother's fighting styles
that he learned from both of them to win
in the end and his father's teachings
did have an importance of some sort so
which would make wenwu's total score at
13 13. yeah 13.
um yes before we do our last five
daddies be sure to head to
directorsmerch.com to grab our newest
latest obsession shirt cosmic daydream
this shirt inspired by the miss marvel
series is limited edition and won't last
long and when you buy this latest
obsession shirt you unlock the
opportunity to get a custom shout out on
inside marvel our miss marvel after show
hosted by eric voss and me mt the man
with the dimples so check out all of our
awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com yeah get one for
your dad hey get one for a dad get one
in the name of dad in the name of badge
and where would dads be without their
kids like do you know a kid who has a
dad just buy a shirt for for that
special dad
i want to do a kind of controversial
parental figure and that is yondu udonta
so as we know from guardians of the
galaxy yondu was given orders to kidnap
peter quill as a child but when he found
out that turning him over would mean
peter's death he decided to keep him in
turn raising him to be a ravager now
it's no secret that growing up he would
constantly tease peter and tell him that
his shipmates wanted to eat him which
scared peter quite a bit understandably
and eventually led to him leaving the
ravagers however yondu hunted him down
when he obtained an orb that yondu and
his crew wanted and when he caught up to
him yondu beat him up for betraying him
and almost killed him before being
convinced by peter and gamora to turn
his sights on a greater treasure fast
forward to guardians 2 and yondu and his
crew are helping the guardians of the
galaxy fight ego and yanu ultimately
sacrifices himself by saving peter's
life by giving him his flight suit and
thereby
suffocating and freezing to death
tale as old as time
and
i will now let mt say the line that he's
been dying to say go for it
he may have been your father boy but it
wasn't your daddy oh my god am i am i
michael rooker i think i am that's
perfectly delivered i couldn't even tell
the difference we might get a copyright
strike for that i don't know
so some people think he's the best dad a
guy could have and some people think
he's pretty bad what do we think
well
we gotta look at the numbers because
love for kid
i would say that that's like at least a
four i mean i think he did love peter
and he saved his life but like more than
once in fact but he got a little bit too
close to killing him when he caught him
in the first movie so like like he was
literally like mid whistle but like he
was about to literally about to kill him
what one strong whistle that kid was
dead you can give him some points for
not killing him but when a dad almost
kills his son you gotta look twice at it
you gotta be like
okay all right i'm gonna bring treatment
right down to a three though cause he
might have brought him into the family
but he also picked on him roughed him up
scared him and did a pretty bad job of
showing him any sort of warmth about
involvement though
involvement i mean i mean he raised him
for sure but also he was raised to steal
so a bit of a questionable upbringing so
i'll still give it a four okay emotional
availability though
yeah that's true i mean he had a really
tough exterior and criticized peter for
being a softy for having feelings which
how dare you as a as a man have feelings
um that kind of talks of masculinity
it's a two for me uh because men should
be able to express their feelings preach
empty preach
so for dependability while he did try to
kill him once this dude not only kept
him alive as a child and took him under
his wing but he made the ultimate
sacrifice and died for him that's as
dependable as it gets so
i totally agree but gotta admit though
as a role model he's probably not the
best seeing as he stole kidnapped and
ravaged in general just general ravaging
not a good role model thing but at
yondu's funeral peter did say that yondu
had what he idolized in david hasselhoff
as a kid and that was going on kick-ass
adventures hooking up with hot women and
fighting robots so that's gotta be worth
the point so bumping that up to a two
because you know
that's just great your great role model
potential when you're um kicking kicking
robots and hooking up with hot women all
that stuff i mean
my dad does it no he's you're special
towards women i love you dad i'm sorry
i'm sorry
so that gives yondu an official score of
19 which is
bad at all actually not bad at all um
and i feel like we gotta
address a big purple elephant in the
room all right yeah we gotta do it well
do i would never speak to him again he
knows what he did
oh okay does he owe you money that's uh
jeez but no there's one mcu bad dad that
i feel like most people think of when
they think of when they hear this prompt
is it thanosano
has quite a few um
[Music]
um adopted a stolen
children um there's gamora and nebula of
course and then there's also ebony ma uh
cull obsidian uh proxima midnight um and
corvus glaive all of whom he stole from
lands that he conquered and that dude
was just literally just collecting
orphans like pokemon it was uh quite
quite weird he trained them to be
warriors and assassins and frequently
made gamora and nebula fight each other
which is not a good thing for sisters to
do if your sister's out there do not
fight with violence and whenever nebula
would lose he would literally replace
one of her body parts with a robotic
body part to try to make her stronger
instead of giving her encouragement or
anything he was just like all right this
arm is just not good enough let's give
her a stronger arm you dummy you know
empty that's why i'm so weak it's
because my dad never replaced my body
parts when i lost a fight man
dads need to step their game up these
days you know it's like if you're not
replacing your kids body parts what are
you doing what are you doing what are we
doing here smh come on man well gamora
was the first to openly hate thanos
eventually both sisters turned against
him and fought against him and their
other siblings fast forward to avengers
infinity war and thanos in an attempt to
force gamora to tell him the location of
the soul stone on vormir tortures nebula
in front of her so gemara gives in and
then they go to the location of the soul
stone on vormir only to throw gamora off
of a freaking cliff when he's told in
order to get the soul stone he must
sacrifice someone he loves so is this
potentially the mcu's worst father anna
well
okay so love for kid i can't exactly
give a one because he did love gamora
otherwise he wouldn't have gotten the
stone when he sacrificed her
but the other five kids i don't think he
gave a rat's ass about so i'll give it a
two
you know what yeah i think the two was
fair because he he definitely did love
gamora as we saw um he proved it by
getting that pebble um but regardless
about how he felt though he definitely
gets a one for how he treated them
because he even killed gamora who he
supposedly loved and i don't think
throwing someone off a cliff is a love
language like it's been a while since
i've read the love language book but um
you know i've only i only saw five and
uh but you know they're always adding
new languages every day so maybe
throwing something off a cliff is just a
way to tell some of you love them throw
your dad off a cliff next post
next father's day you know what to do
get a groupon
get a group
but yes um combine that with all the
torture and killing of their families i
don't think you could give them a score
higher than a one year that'd be kind of
oh yeah
agreed agreed for involvement i'll say a
three because while he was involved in
their lives all growing up
most of that was making them fight and
kill so you know not exactly taking them
to swimming practice well you mean
that's the same thing as swimming
practice anna that's the same thing
i went to the wrong camp growing up
[Laughter]
i went to camp hunger games and i'd only
give thanos a three for emotional
availability because while i do feel
like you'd hear them out on whatever you
wanted to talk about he even chooses to
sit on the ground instead of the throne
after gamora says that she always headed
the throne in an infinity war i don't
think that you could convince him to say
not kill half the people in the universe
with any number of tears he's he was
pretty dead set on doing that he was not
surprised gamora should try that and
dependability definitely gets a one did
we did we mention he replaced nebulous
body parts and tortured her like can you
is it possible to rely on a guy like
that no he shows time and time again
that his plans come first and he expects
his kids to put those plans above all
else too
[Music]
he's gonna watch this video he's gonna
feel disrespected but as far as being a
role model goes it kind of depends on
the perspective like gamora and nebula
both ended up hating him and while you
could argue that his other kids along
with gamora when she was younger strived
to make him proud a big part of that was
probably due to fear brainwashing or
just straight up stockholm syndrome so
he gets a 2.
which brings thanos to a 12 which is the
lowest so far but
is he the worst dad we can think of i'm
going to talk about my personal least
favorite general dracov oh this piece of
[ __ ] i hate this man uh he was her dad
right yeah yeah he was technically a dad
yeah hard to believe but yeah draco was
antonia dracov aka taskmaster's father
dracov was in charge of the red room the
soviet training program that turned
young women into weapons he was the one
that bought natasha romanov from her
family and then had her mom assassinated
when she went looking for natasha but
this isn't about his relationship with
natasha but with antonia and oddly
enough dracov never put antonia through
the red room growing up he allowed her
to live a relatively normal life going
to school and even having a pretty close
relationship with her dad things changed
however when black widow and hawkeye in
an assassination attempt detonated a
bomb in drakov's office where antonio
was visiting although they both survived
antonia's face was disfigured and to
keep her alive drakov put a chip in the
back of her neck that allowed him
complete control over her and after that
he did put her through the red room and
turned her into an assassin that could
mimic people's fighting styles from then
on although she was by his side as an
assassin he treated her lukewarm at best
talking about her as if she's not there
and even calling her difficult to look
at when she's finally freed from her
mind control by natasha her first words
are is he gone
chilling
yo that dude was a piece of [ __ ] i hate
drakov why'd you make him so
terrible it's bad it's so bad literally
i cannot stand drake off that dude
straight up sucks but for love of kid
the fact that he didn't want to put her
in the red room before the accident is
probably a good indicator that there was
some
type of genuine love there that
seemingly almost completely disappeared
after the accident when she got more
ugly what the [ __ ] was that about drakov
you piece of [ __ ] like are you just i'm
just you're not like you were totally
fine before i'm not gonna put you in the
red room but now that you're ugly
i don't care if you die what is wrong
with you i'm sorry ugly duckling sort of
situation
yikes like the ugly duckling gets uh spy
training i would read that book first of
all
read that book
i really would too that'd be amazing but
some of the things he says and does
might have a reason to them like maybe
she's difficult to look at because he's
pained remembering the accident sort of
like when wu was paying to look at shia
um because he shilling reminded him of
his dead wife but either way he gets a
three maximum and that's pretty generous
um go to hell drakov i hope you're
burning there as we speak the end i'll
agree with that
but i mean the treatment's got to be a
one he barely acknowledges her as a
person and considering her first words
when she regains consciousness are is he
gone like dear god that speaks volumes
plus he was constantly berating and
abusing women in front of her and just
talking [ __ ] about females in general
not one i feel like involvement though
it's got to be like a three like thanos
got because it's the sort of the same
deal here he kept her alive by his side
all growing up but also turned her into
this mindless assassin for most of her
life so sort of just basically using
their his kid as a tool like thanos did
right and it's a one for emotional
availability like you think you can talk
to this man bro i don't know what you're
talking about i when i had my first high
school crush i went straight to drakov
and he was like hey
how strong is this crush what does she
like would you like to join the red robe
and i was like no draco what's wrong
with you
i don't think that's a good
heart-to-heart mt i hate to break it to
you yeah it didn't go well
and dependability is also a one he
already has literally put her in the
line of fire by making her his bodyguard
and he is more than happy to run and
leave her behind when he is in danger
dad of the year and
for role model potential he's still the
one who wants to grow up to kidnap girls
give them hysterectomies and make them
killers this guy is the worst the worst
the score does seem to reflect this
because draco's score is a staggering
ten
um i would love to give him a negative
ten i award you no points
and may god have mercy on your soul well
we have to play fair we have to be
impartial judges empty yeah but i need a
palette cleanser after that one hit me
with a palette cleanser please all right
i've got a dab that most people love to
hate and that is alexi schafter cough in
black widow we learned that alexis
shostakov the first soviet russian super
soldier is sent undercover to act as an
american family alongside his surrogate
wife molina vostikov and his two
surrogate daughters natasha romanov and
elena belova why can you later have the
off like they had a whole off theme
going faster off romanov shostakov yeah
you did agree with those names though
gotta say yes really good and they lived
a seemingly normal life in ohio for
three years before shield agents found
them and they had to flee
[Music]
at this point alexi and molina were
working for the red room and natasha had
been through it once but elena had not
and the three years that elena had spent
with her surrogate family was real to
her and after the family escaped alexi
gave the two girls back to drakoff to go
through the red room despite them
pleading to stay which is really stuff
and the next time we see alexi is in
prison due to dracov having incarcerated
him and the now adult reconnected
sisters rescue him from the prison in an
attempt to get information about the red
room's location and after being reunited
alexi shows his immaturity and inability
to let go of his glorified past fighting
captain america and he calls their three
years undercover tedious and says he's
proud of how many people his girls have
killed over the years and is mostly
concerned with fitting into his old red
guardian costume and reuniting a spark
with their surrogate mother molina and
he teams up with them to take down the
red room and afterwards the relationship
seems to be on the mend as they part
ways again
so this dude is definitely goofy but is
he a bad parent
well
looking at love for kid there's
definitely some level of love there but
how much love can he really have for two
people he was assigned to spend three
years with you know and he was
definitely thinking more of himself than
his daughters over the years so i'm
gonna give him a three but what about
treatment of kids
it's a mixed bag i think he was probably
a pretty good dad in those three years
and was able to connect with elena later
on by singing her her favorite song but
also i wouldn't say handing them over to
the red room and then peacing out was
the coolest thing a dad could do within
the world not cool at all plus there was
that general selfish pig-headedness that
he showed them when they rescued him but
he did help them fight in the end so i'd
say that's another three yeah for
involvement i'd say maybe a two though
because
three out of thirty-something years
isn't a great ratio and he was even kind
of mentally checked out during those
three years since he really stressed how
boring those years were which is so
harsh
sort of like odin being bored when loki
was complaining to her was like ah oh my
god alexi wishes he could go through the
odin's sleep for those three years i'll
tell you what but yes emotional
availability gets a four though because
he does have that heart to hurt with the
elena when she's upset but also he
definitely seems like the type to make a
joke out of everything or bring it back
to himself and his amazing fights with
captain america
valid for dependability i mean can you
really depend on this guy to save your
life or even like to take your clothes
out of the dryer when they're done he
pulls through for the girls in the end
so for that i'll give him a three but
like i wouldn't ask him to look after my
cat i don't even have a cat but i still
wouldn't ask him so there that's true
and then as a role model this dude's
gotta be like a two i mean the girls are
already better role models than him so i
would hope that they would aspire to be
more than a sloppy dude who was super
obsessed with himself and worked for the
red room there's there's better things
that you could be in life and that
brings alexi shostakov to a 17. i gotta
give it to him though at least he brings
some good comedic relief you know yes
so funny i can't i cannot wait to see
him again um he's like one of my
favorite new mcu characters i would love
to see him again absolutely yes now mt
we have one more slot and i think i know
exactly who it should go to
ooh
so for this last ad we're going right
back to the guardians of the galaxy
universe
ooh
a lot of bad dads in that one
what are we talking about uh rocket
raccoon and uh
groot
hey don't don't you put that curse on
rocket raccoon's name listen how dare
you
no but this dead is one that we're only
introduced to vaguely up until the
second movie and that is peter quill's
biological father ego oh
big time douche mega douche yeah the
largest the largest douche so ego is a
celestial who turned himself into a
living planet and then created an avatar
of himself in order to
spread his seeds across the galaxy to
create extensions of himself therefore
the one and only ryan reynolds asked me
to help us all celebrate with the mother
of all cocktails
the vasectomy lord knows i need one you
know i'm gonna have a breakdown
so he wanted to basically spread the
extensions of himself thereby causing
mass extinction to all living beings
aside from himself hashtag just dad
things so he'd go from planet to planet
impregnating people and then piecing out
instructing yondu to collect these kids
and bring them to him later however
every kid except peter lacked the
celestial dna so he killed them when he
heard that peter held an infinity stone
and didn't die he was like oh family
reunion time and went out to find him
he finds him gains his trust discloses
his plan for peter to help him take over
existence puts him in a trance and then
reveals that he was the one who put the
tumor in peter's mom's brain
this causes peter to snap out of it and
turn on ego so ego sends a giant blue
energy tentacle stabbing through peter's
chest tells him he's gonna spend the
next thousand years of battery and
breaks his favorite walkman
so
let's write rates yes i'd say love of
kids is probably a one since he uh
killed off thousands of his children
when they didn't meet his standards uh
but even worse he broke a peter's
walkman no unacceptable so uh that
definitely gives him a one he basically
only cared about what peter could do for
him and not peter the person himself
right for treatment of kids i'll throw
on a single point considering it's as
you specified treatment of alive kids
and up until he tried to turn peter into
a battery he's somewhat chill but the
killing of his mom and breaking the
walkman and attempted murder were not
cool so
yeah generally not cool things to do
right um to your kid or to anyone don't
do that um but involvement gets a big
old one considering that he wasn't part
of peter's life at all until he had
something that ego wanted so yeah yeah
and i'd say emotional availability is a
one two because after all the only
person he started genuinely getting
close with he gave a brain tumor because
he was having too many feelings
i can't have those feelings
totally terrible those feelings they
come back comes back around they always
come back around
um and yeah dependability has also got
to be a one because again he was gone
for 99.9 percent of peter's life growing
up so
so
maybe controversial but i think we
should give role model potential a two
because for a brief minute there being
an ultimate being was not too bad of a
deal it was only egos corruption that
mucked things up but there was a spot of
potential for something really beautiful
in different hands giving ego a total
score of eight so who is the worst dad
in the mcu the mathematically proven
answer is ego the living planet and here
is the ranking of all the other dads on
our list
hello this is alexa the editor i'm
briefly interrupting to add bucky to the
dad list i know he ain't a dad
but i can make him one
[Music]
honorable mention to lauffy loki's
biological frost giant dad now the thing
that keeps him from this list is there's
a what if episode where loki wasn't born
a run and lauffy did raise him and loki
turned out to be a pretty chill dude and
since the what if universes are canon it
made ranking him a little bit too tricky
um another audible mention that we have
is norman osborne and adrian toomes aka
the green goblin and the vulture in the
spider-man movies who we considered but
who turned out to be pretty chill dads
despite being villains so good job i
guess especially a plus
[Laughter]
but this brings us to a box of scraps
built it in the cave in the boxes crabs
wow my first time in the box of scraps
it's beautiful are we inside the box of
scraps
all right buddy who is your favorite mcu
dad
ooh
well i gotta say i have a favorite mcu
daddy if you will
is
scott oh my god you stole mine so good
he's so good he plays with his daughter
and he's so cute and i love his dynamics
yeah
he's my favorite mcu daddy for sure i'm
gonna steal your answer and say scott
lang as well because like there is no
dad in the mcu better than scott lang
he's so good with cassie and like to the
point where like i don't know it's just
like cassie wants to be like his dad and
like she she wants to be
like an ant-man style here which she
will be in young avengers so i'm very
excited to see her live up to her
father's legacy um but yes
that is it for this episode of big
questions thank you so much to anna for
joining me on this episode she's amazing
follow her at it's anna vance and on
twitter and all of her other amazing
stuff she does especially on tick tock
she's really great and you can follow me
at mastertainment you can follow the new
rockstars here on youtube and all of our
social media platforms and make sure to
hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
video but yes you guys are amazing we
love you guys so much and we'll see you
guys next time goodbye
bye
[Music]
you